the story of Bigg Boss is one of
downfall born in 1935 in joining the US
military as a teenager he became the
apprentice to a legendary soldier known
as the boss
the young soldier known as John at the
time mastered combat and espionage
techniques under the boss's training
until 1959 when both were duty-bound to
go their separate ways
at some point between 1962 and 1964 John
was asked to join Fox a secret CIA unit
specifically designed to handle
top-secret infiltration missions his new
code name was Naked Snake but his first
major assignment known as the virtuous
mission was a failure tasked with
retrieving a Soviet scientist called
Nikolai Sokolov from Russia naked snakes
mission was thwarted by his old mentor
the boss who appeared to have defected
to the USSR snake was nearly killed the
boss captured Sokolov and a nuclear
missile had been detonated turning this
covert operation into headline news
placed in intensive care
Naked Snake was interrogated by the US
military and given an ultimatum he would
be pardoned but only if he returns to
Russia eliminates the boss and recovers
Sokolov the mission quickly went awry
Sokolov was killed snake was tortured
with one of his eyes shot out and an
experimental mobile nuclear missile
launcher known as the shagger hood was
captured by the boss's Cobra unit to
sling surprise the boss helps him escape
from the torture chamber he returns to
destroy the shagger hood leaving with
him one final mission to eliminate the
boss this is the first major turning
point the snake he manages to kill the
boss against his wishes and only for
duty to his country in his final moments
with his mentor he discovers that the
virtuous mission was a ruse and that the
boss's supposed defection was part of a
bigger plan concocted by a secret
organization within the White House
known as the Philosopher's
he is given the Distinguished Service
Cross and the new codename Big Boss but
he becomes a loner blaming himself for
putting his country before anything else
and retires from Fox five years later he
joins a secret multinational
organization known as the Patriots this
was a reformed version of the
philosophers but under new leadership
they are effectively an Illuminati group
but the Patriots betray Big Boss
extracting his genes to create
genetically enhanced soldiers his DNA is
also used to create three suns co named
liquid snake solid snake and solid snake
big boss leaves the Patriots and creates
his own private mercenary group known as
militare Sam fontelle using his
legendary reputation to amass an army
unaligned to any country then in 1974
big boss's mercenary army entered Costa
Rica to destroy what appeared to be the
next evolution of the shagger Hut design
known as a metal gear he also expands
his own army which is now located on an
offshore plant called mother base and
meets two characters for the first time
Chico and Paz one year later
Big Boss discovers that both Chico and
pairs have been captured and taken to
Camp Omega a maximum-security military
prison located on the southern tip of
Cuba Big Boss successfully retrieves the
tube but when returning to mother base
he finds that the base is under attack
by a mysterious military unit known as
zom the majority of his army is killed a
mother base is destroyed escaping in a
helicopter
Big Boss discovers that Paz is carrying
a bomb inside her which detonates and
downs the aircraft seemingly killing
everyone inside including Big Boss after
the events of the phantom pain big
boss's downfall is complete he creates a
military fortress in South Africa which
he calls outer heaven in 1995 he takes a
Russian scientist prisoner
and forces him to build a new metal gear
doing so would give Big Boss global
military influence but then one of his
three genetically engineered sons Solid
Snake manages to infiltrate outer heaven
destroys metal gear and blows up the
base
Big Boss only just survives and
continues with this plan two years later
in 1997 he takes control of Zanzibar a
small country in East Africa where he
attempts to build another metal gear but
the plan is once again stopped by Solid
Snake who this time confronts Big Boss
in an underground base burns him alive
and leaves him for dead
Big Boss his story after this becomes
more tragic his body is found by the
Patriots kept alive but induced into a
coma and once again his DNA is
researched and used to manufacture
next-generation military units in Metal
Gear Solid 4 which is chronologically
the final game in the series big boss is
awakened from his coma his legend ends
at the gravestone of his former mentor
the boss where he needs Solid Snake for
the final time and shares one peaceful
cigarette with his son before passing
away
you